so
my name is kyoto i work at this company
called treasure data
um we're the original author of the
software fill in the open source
log management software and
can i get a quick show of hands how many
of you have heard of it
like fluency oh that's pretty good
how many of you have used it one awesome
then i can go back and tell our cto that
i have a conversion rate of like seven
percent
so that's me on the internet that's
actually me last year
uh i i tend to look down even when i
talk
and apparently it started very early on
that's me when i was four
so i haven't really changed so i'm go if
i if i look down like start clapping so
that i know that i'm looking down
that's right and yeah i work for this
company and
they'll probably appreciate it if i show
the logo
so look at the camera
thank you um
so i i tend to be very skeptical of
other people
telling me stuff so i'm going to qualify
why
you shouldn't listen to me i'm not an
ops engineer
and how many how many of you here like
consider yourselves as like ops person
so what else are you guys
programmers dev
marketing i'm in marketing so product
awesome so hopefully like my talk is not
going to really offend any any
contingency
but i am a marketing person i work in
developer marketing
and especially focusing on our open
source technologies uh
fluentd is the biggest one but we are
also the original author of
message pack which is a binary
json-like serialization protocol
and also my laptop is thinkpad
running windows and it's like instantly
losing street cred
properly but also here here are reasons
why you should listen to me i'm one of
the core maintainers of fluency
and i mainly focus on community
management
and community management in this context
is actually very technical answering
all sorts of questions on the mailing
list we just reached
500 threads my name is probably on like
400 of them
and i used to be a programmer very
active in open source stuff
and there's actually one patch in php
that i landed
and it was for open ssl so i guess it
was like a lost cause to begin with
and uh i'm also a data nerd um before
i started to work here at treasure data
i was um i worked in finance uh doing a
lot of number crunching
so the topic of the day is why fluency
like why not like rsa for example
and by way of like talking a little bit
more about myself because
i haven't clearly talked enough about
myself i
used to be a data scientist and before
it was cool
more specifically i worked as a
quantitative analyst in finance
and that's like a less sexy term for
data scientists because
this is what i did uh you acquire data
and you try to like analyze it
and you sort of ruminate on your
findings and you tell the traders what
to do
and you rinse and repeat i did that for
two and a half years
straight out of school studying math and
computer science
and like that step is like very
small in this diagram but in reality
it goes something like this so you
acquire data
that's what you think it's like what
like there's this thing that says
invalid utf-8 and like
i'm i have no idea so like you fixing
coding issues
like latin one and all that stuff then
you run your analysis and matlab are
excel and you get like just like
division by zero
like some columns are missing and what
highest is possible
so like you know you yell at the
engineers i was on the research side i
was like
i go to the data engineers it's like how
come those are missing like oh the
switch failed and like this didn't load
it's gonna take another two days i'm
like i'm the one who's gonna get yelled
at
by engineers i mean sorry traders
and that you repeat i did this for two
and a half years
and like eventually i ran out of
patience and i was like
god this is not that hard right so i was
like just show me the logs
and they're like sure like yeah just
show me the logs i'm going to parse it
myself
it looks like this and i'm like
maybe this is not the data engineer's
fault
maybe there's some like a greater issue
so i actually talked a lot of customers
at treasure data and we are a big data
service company and one of the things
that i learned is
in many organizations uh the priority of
logging is not really high
like if you went after like a product
person like what do you think about
like log management they're like what
okay if you go to ceos like
hey i think you guys should start
structuring your logs and manage it
better it's like
well i need to raise money right but
what's actually
very high priority is analytics everyone
wants to know
how well their like design is doing how
their feature is doing
and everyone's like hey like how can i
tell like if there's a new variation
that i propose is better than your
version
right and
the connection here is you need logs
to do honest analytics and
this is actually something that a lot of
people don't realize
especially when you start to grow
more predictably and you start to like
tweak
little things here and there to like
increase the number of sign ups
or when you get to that phase
what you realize is like oh my god i
don't have enough data to actually
check what we're doing is right because
we totally skipped that like
logging and thinking about that issue
earlier
so the lesson here is you need logs
anyway
so start managing it today your service
or future
product or company might grow like in
like three months six months two years
and you're gonna need that log
and because some of your ops and this is
something that they've touched on
outage is like something that everyone
notices like nobody
pays attention to like operations until
like [ __ ] hits a fan
and everyone starts like panicking right
why is the website down or like
why are like all these users complaining
and logs you need lots
to troubleshoot outages and especially
uh you need it for two reasons one is
like
to fix it in in the first place like you
need to know what the hell is going on
but when you're doing post hoc analysis
you do need that logs
handy so that you can actually run stats
on them
so logs are important log everything
and like in many organizations that i've
seen
people start to realize this like okay
we need to start logging stuff so that
we actually know what's going on
and but because this is done in a very
very uncoordinated matter
using like oursing script here by the
script here like pro one liner there
and this was the case at the finance
form that i worked at
you get a system like this and it's a
gigantic mess
oh i have this i i only care about the
data coming from the removal app because
i'm the pm for it
so i'm going to ask my engineer to get
the data from that and i'm going to put
it into mobility because that's what i
look at
and the other person is like oh i have
those log files and parse them and put
it into hadoop
to do those in my predictions and they
start to
depend on each other and before you know
it
it becomes very very unmanageable and
this is a big
risk for vp of engineering or cto or
anyone
who is ultimately responsible for the
technological future of the company
and i'm gonna this is gonna look really
markety
but this is what we try to achieve with
the fluency
we call it a unified logging layer
but essentially have this one piece of
middleware
in between your data sources and data
destinations
to take care of routing filtering and
aggregating and such
so that's why we built it
so i'm going to give you a very simple
overview
it has a ton of stuff that have like 30
40 minutes
and but i'm more than happy to dive into
the details if you guys have any
question at the end
so i'm gonna start with everyone's
favorite example which is apache logs
like it's when i talk to customers it
seems to me that most of the data just
come from apache web service
and the patcher locks look something
like this
it's fairly readable like i you know at
first class you wouldn't know what those
dashes are
but eventually you figure out it's
something like this i
put it as a json there's a host a user
method
path hdb status code
and that's actually the first thing that
a fluency does and it's one of its key
features which is
it tries to structure logs of data
sources
so you have all these data sources
and when it's coming in it gets
processed json
sorry then it gets possible with json
but the natural question now is how does
femininity know
where to send the data to like how do
you
how does it know like it needs to send a
bunch of logs into mongodb
but twitter fees into like i don't know
logarithmic let's say
um the key is uh
we actually have a little metadata
attached to
the the core data so it parses the logs
and it has two other pieces of data
that comprises the smallest unit of data
we call it event fluent events
one is timestamp uh when did it come
and the other is tag which is the second
one up there it says like web dot
access so what tag does is tag tells
fluid
where to send the data to and you'll see
this better
with a configuration file later but at
the highest level
from like 3000 foot view this is what it
does um
when the data comes in you assign it a
tag so that fluency knows
which tag goes to which data
destinations
that's to be honest that that's what it
is
but i am going to give you examples
uh from actually someone else's slide
if i know how to do this
need to get out
here guys yeah so one other maintainer
gave a talk at the red dot rubyconf
last month and uh he talked about flindy
patterns so i'm gonna go through them
quickly because what i realized is like
i i've given talks where i just went
through old architecture
and people started look like okay i'm
gonna go to twitter
facebook like this is so complex so i'm
gonna talk about how you can actually
use it
so that at least you'll be interested um
one is very simple
uh relogs from somewhere like files and
update it to somewhere else
well you read it from one file and put
it into another file so imagine you have
like 2000 web servers
you want to aggregate all of your logs
into a central server and zip it up
that's something you can do with fluendy
but maybe you want to put into mongodb
because uh
someone else in the organization is
using it and like you want to do
analytics in it
there's a plugin for that so you can
just like write out to mongodb
maybe you want to fit into my sql
maybe you want to put it to
elasticsearch hadoop hdfs
and the list goes on there are actually
about 300 plugins now
and i'm pretty sure like 100
some of them are output plugins
supporting different storage layers
you have to yes but i'm pretty sure
for your data source there's a plugin
for it already
sorry data destination redshift
bigquery and i believe there's one for
logley too
but i'm not sure and the second one is
uh it's almost like data relay uh
middleware so like the input events come
in i don't know
like tcp packets like syslog events and
it falls into like other um machines
and it basically intelligently routes so
that
like for this event i'm gonna send it
there as for this event i'm gonna send
it down there do any of the
outputs have support for like encryption
or authentication
uh it's going to come up there is one
that
sends data over ssl and this is more of
the same
except here you can actually do
failovers so if
you send heartbeat if it doesn't respond
it fails over to the other one
and starts sending to that one and also
it supports uh
weighted load balancing among
different uh destination fluid nodes
so it can sort of act as logging
load balancer as well
and this is the one about ssl there's a
plugin called secure ford which allows
you to send data
from fluenty to fluendo over ssl
what we don't have yet is encryption
over tcp
and hdb so that when the data is coming
into 20 that'll be an issue
and connect with other middleware um a
lot of people are already using some
kind of
logging or some kind of other
data ingestion middleware
and it's it's always a tough cell to
just like oh you should cut it out and
replace it with my new awesome thing
like that doesn't work so we try to
co-exist with other middleware and
there's like plugins for that
syslog film scribe kafka are
pretty popular ones and
this is a very common use case too um
when it when you're start when you're
trying to test like a new data storage
system
you probably want to keep a copy and
store it somewhere that you know it's
safe
like whether it's s3 or local file
system uh there's a plugin for that it's
called copy
it copies data streams as many times you
want and
send it to one direction to one data
destination
and send a copy the exact duplicate
into another system
and here's where it gets pretty
interesting
a lot of people use it just to like
aggregate data
and store into like uh target systems
but
some people actually try to do more
using the
filter log mechanism that we have so
this one
is it's filtering data i think no it's
counting events by string values
so this is almost like time windowed
group bytes
that you can do against the data and
something like this allows you to do
like anomaly detection so like if you
start to see a lot of 500 status codes
chances are good something is wrong with
your web server so you can send alerts
again using fluency
and another one is like by number values
you can take like weighted average um
moving moving average max min with time
windows
like this is like stuff that you might
do
in graphite but run it against like a
time window thing
and he actually had a lot of examples
um here's another interesting use case
sorry
cursor is usually the data comes in as
data stream right like the tcp
packets or like you you're telling a log
and like you can sort of think of log as
a data stream
but also fluently can
act as like like a chrome
in that it can run a program and to get
the results out
and put it into like different systems
so there's actually have you how many of
you know these that
yeah so it's like this that is this
python utility program that's like
vmstat netstat and all of that combined
to do one nice thing
that sort of acts like top so there is a
plugin called uh
in uh dstat and when you enable it and
run it
what it does is like every x minus every
x seconds
it runs dstat and pipe the output of the
stat
into fluency so
that's one use case the demo that i'm
going to show you is going to use the
twitters
so there's a plugin called in twitter
which allows you to get data from
twitter as the industry
and put into it somewhere else
all right so going back to
my presentation
so all these patterns are really nice
but
i also promise to talk about like in
production use cases
so here are a few so the first one is uh
by the way i love this guy like he makes
my internet much better
and in devops is not correct [ __ ] hit
fan but
[ __ ] hit load balance adam his english
is like you know probably better than
mine
so this is the use case at slideshare
um they were actually one of the
earliest adopters of
uh fluency and the problem that they
were
trying to solve was like as they scaled
their uh
company and like the the reach of the
service
they really wanted to make sure that
they were not just like adding more and
more operations folks
with with their expanding infrastructure
so they wanted to automate this
the system of monitoring their systems
so what they did
is they created this system called
skynet and there's a whole
blog article about that but what they do
is they
instrument every single middleware that
they run under like 500
some servers so basically fluency is
installed on each server and they
collect data like aj proxy logs
uh nginx logs load balances how many
concurrent connections there are
and all of that data is streamed into
their backend system which i think uses
mongodb
and there's like a query api that they
wrote in rails against it
so like the operations folks can look at
the health of the system their
non-technical people can look at the
dashboard and see
like what's trending how many people are
visiting the website and so forth and
the key here is that
there are tools that keep track of like
um
application level statistics like google
analytics right
like the space has been visited this
many times and there are tools to
um investigate systems metrics
like now i guess it's a pretty good one
but what they really liked about fluid
was they could build their own system
on top of fundy that would actually
correlate it to
so for example like the operations
engineer
on call gets paged and he wants to know
like
if it's a middleware issue or maybe like
an application code
being written poorly and he needs to
triage right
and getting all of that data into a
single place
really really accelerates the process of
figuring out where the root cause is
and so that's uh slight share i
highly recommend reading the blog entry
there is a section about fluency but
it's more like fluentd as part of their
bigger
operations and automation slash mod
system
the other tweet is i'll let you guys
read i don't even know what this means
to be honest but
it was kind of fun and
the only way that this is relevant to my
next example
is that they have a lot of data
their company is called gree it's a
japanese social gaming company and
they they they're pretty big company
they're public actually
and what they do is they use full nd for
in-game analytics so this is not really
operations it's more like applications
analytics and product analytics so
how they set it up is they have 2000
plus
game servers ranging from like hundreds
to like you know
a few dozens per title and they want to
collect all the data about like
clicks um which user is dropping off
where
and all of that and they do this with
finding the back
background um collecting data from
applications
uh directly and send it to aggregator
knows for
better throughput so those guys are just
like
focusing on getting data like accepting
like
incoming data and like just passing on
to the aggregators
and aggregators batch them up and pass
it back to
their back end and the back end does all
the analytics
and like there's like dashboard and all
that stuff
so they did about a billion events per
day
and they've been using us pretty uh
heavily for the past two years or so
and so i'm supposed to demo
hopefully the internet is would be
so this is what i did how many of you
watched the world cup
yeah so i was fairly productive
throughout the whole thing
and uh not really but
so what i decided to do for this is uh
i use the use fluendy
to collect a lot of tweets specifically
the ones that
have the hashtag netherlands and
argentina
and i put into like our backend system
but that's not really the important part
um
the idea is you can this is like a less
traditional use of 2d
but getting tweets in and sending into a
destination and what i did was
i took all these tweets and tokenized
them
and tallied up like the world frequency
so
throughout the game what word is like it
how many times so if i have the internet
i should be able to show you like an
example
can you guys see that i'm not sure if
the color is really good
so it's like so right now it says
netherland
argentina and i don't know if you guys
remember a match but
it was zero zero and came down to um uh
penalty kicks
and like argentina won 14.
are you from argentina no okay wait who
here is from argentina
or the netherlands i don't want to
offend either so
okay so like you can do like a couple of
fun things like one is like
messy
uh hopefully this is gonna run
there you go yeah so when he made a goal
he was really everyone was talking about
him so
the other person who made us on the
netherlands team robin
okay so robin is there so let's add a
guy who missed it snyder
and yeah like he gets mentioned a lot
right so
then like you can do a couple of cool
things like
card foul
and like there is a correlation but a
lot of people are talking about yellow
and like
red cards more than foul and the other
thing that i thought it was
i did notice like just reading my
twitter stream like
people people have like some
they they make good use of profanity so
one thing i actually did and it's funny
like i showed this at work
and the first word that everyone typed
was the f-word
and people were very very upset
during the penalty so much more than
like
i i put something that is slightly less
offensive
and apparently that didn't do justice
for the anger
so because the effort's more universal
across the world
i believe yeah yeah so
so this demo that you're showing um is
you're fluent you want me asking sure so
you've got fluency and it's
it's pulling the twitter api for those
things
it parses and then it spits out json
yeah
and it has broken it up but of course
the analysis you're showing here is is
some javascript code
driving queries to a possible database
correct so
what you're seeing there is oops i'm
telling you how the data is
is stored in postgres i don't know if
that's too low level
um sure i can show you
guys
okay so
yep this is the only way you can do this
when you're on windows
if the internet is i mean yeah i mean if
it's true i'm just curious what's the
apm
yeah i can um i can release the code it
has been indexed it's basically it's
indexed in the database yeah so
the the real the real reason why i
did this this way is i couldn't code
fast enough
so that i couldn't launch the thing
while the game is going on but in theory
a lot of this can be done
uh online without actually having
uh something like treasure data in
between um
treasure data is doing a lot of the
magic here treasure well so what trigger
data is doing
is it takes the the tweet right which is
like
i love messi for example and it like
normalizes that
and tokenize it so that it's i love and
messy
then we and it just runs one big uh sql
job
that tallies that up per word per minute
so yeah what i learned over time is
like i can show you the command line
demo and like
it looks pretty visually boring so i
just decided to throw together some
front end i guess the data and
yeah so that's pretty much it in terms
of speaking
so i'd love to take any questions about
fluenty or
the world cup can you talk about the
scalability of blue and d
like sure how big installations get
yeah sure so
the honest answer is it depends um
but when you have like a reasonably
powered machine with
like minimum like just accepting data
coming from
a downstream fluency node and sending it
to that another fluid
node it can achieve about like 13 to 17
000 messages per core
and the the thing is one thing i didn't
say
is fluenty is written in a combination
of ruby and c and
it's mostly ruby with all the
performance critical parts
in c so the problem is the global
interpreter lock and there are a couple
of ways around this
one is run it in multi-process mode
so that you'd be essentially running
multiple fluency processes on a single
machine
as they take advantage of multiple cpus
and the other
is sort of like and this is where the
forward or aggregator pattern
comes in when you accept when you have a
lot of like incoming um
requests just like accepting those is
going to take up a lot of cpu
so you basically defer the task of
parsing that data
and structure structuring it as json to
your downstream um
aggregated service that's another way to
do it
is it the idea here it's kind of just
like a lot of the other log frameworks
is to try to get the data
in a structured data yeah as much as you
can yeah like
people use like log for j like json
output to try to get things in and just
save all that cpu time
yeah i mean this is like age-old
argument of
are the logs for people or machines
right and
the answer is both and the thing is
like those two are not even like
mutually exclusive
propositions like json is imminently
readable like hell it's probably more
readable than certain text formats
because it's actually annotated with the
semantic meanings attached to each field
so that we chose json pretty much
because it is
the most popular one in the web world uh
it could have been something else
but yet the key thing is that as soon as
you get the data
you want to assign it a reasonable
structure that's flexible
but also it allows different people to
understand
what it is and i have this theory that
the farther apart the the site of data
acquisition
and the site of like data usage
are uh sorry the site of like
the data being parsed semantically are
the the more trouble there is in the
organization
is when i was a trader like a
quantitative trader what would happen is
i'd be writing my python script and all
of a sudden my prediction starts like
arriving and i realized that my parser
is wrong
now and that's because the software
engineers change the format
and this shouldn't happen right like if
i was always getting json like at least
when the start
thing started to go bad i was like all
right the field name is different
probably something changed downstream so
i rec like a lot of people ask me like
should i use lock stash should i use
hekas like
should i use like your thing and my
answer is like yes
you use something that allows you to uh
structure and manage your logs like
much much better than i'm gonna are sync
those files and i'm gonna run this my
script
because i just need like those three
three fields like that
that's not gonna scale
like commercial software no sorry it's
open source apache 2.0 licensed
some plugins are mit that depends on
like
mit or something else possibly because
that depends on
the plug-in author but everything in the
core is 3.0
yeah so
what's the role of treasure data other
than you know
it's a really good question maybe i
should never learn the answer because i
get paid to work on open source
um what we realize is that so treasure
data is a cloud service
we provide big data managed service on
on the cloud so that our customers can
focus on analytics
and actually analyzing data as opposed
to like data plumbing
and like scaling out to like hundreds of
servers
we do all of that elastically and
automatically
but what we realized that if you have
any cloud service
the data has to get to your service
somehow
and it doesn't magically happen so
we actually originally wrote fluentd as
our data collector
but then we realized that our customers
wanted to use it
but it hurt our feelings a little bit
but they're like
i'm actually not so sure about sending
my like pci compliance data to you guys
i still want to send it to our like own
on-premises backend
like can you guys open source it so
that's what we did
and it's it's been a very very um
good experiment i would say
like having part of our technology open
source
and being used with like various other
systems
because it's not like we can do
everything
right as a company so that's the idea
we'll see how how well the experiment
goes
um one thing you haven't really talked
about is actually sending data
can i send you know flat text and i said
json can i send
you know encoded data yeah so that's
actually handled by the
so i didn't talk about plugins because
that would get into the like fairly
complex um
so plugin has this pluggable
architecture
and mainly there are input plugins and
output plugins so upper plugins is
straightforward you buffer data and
output to different systems
input plugins is what enables you to get
data into fluency
so there's aim forward which assumes the
data is coming from another fluency
instance
there's entail which tells log files
there's ntcp which is actually tcp
packets
and you give it a parser there's insist
log
i just use in twitter which basically
pulls twitter and get the data in
so and so forth
for example
you know you know converter
yep and then i sent you [ __ ] yeah
so if the data is coming in as a
protocol buffer you probably need to
write a parser for it
but there's a parser plug-in framework
inside like that
one of the most common architectures
like you were saying earlier like
cabana is really awesome to be able to
look at stuff like a lot of people
taking like fluency and putting things
into elasticsearch and looking at them
with savannah or
what are the most common like
architectures yeah so there are two
common use cases one is definitely
elasticsearch kibana and
i mean there's a long slash too and i
don't think that layer
i have nothing mean to say about log
slash in that regard i even tell some
people that
hey if you use logstash you get the
commercial support from elasticsearch
the other use case though is a lot of
our users use it with like
analytics backend like whether it's
hadoop
or sometimes like redshift which is like
database by amazon
a bigquery which is like also like an
analytic database by but
by google and i think part of the reason
is probably where we started like
we we built this originally
to address our customers needs to
collect application logs for analytics
so a lot of people probably drew
inspiration from that and started using
with their own
analytics back but at the end of the day
it is like a lock collector so
wherever you want to get the data from
get it and put it wherever you want
yeah so one thing for example let's say
i'm personally using scribe and one
thing that's nice
you know things are very simple you
cannot do anything right yeah go from
from a to point b
so 3d you can do a lot of things right
you can go from point a convert
do some calculations b 17.3 etc which
kind of reduce the
increase the risk of for example losing
packets or
you know stuff like that does apparently
that do anything to your ad for that
yeah so uh that's a good point that i
also gloss over
which is a fluency is a very very um
i should oh pretty well designed
buffering system
so by default you can choose the buffer
either in memory or
on desk and it retries uh
with like the exponential back off and
so that is like note to node like with
like
just like one note one node but one of
the examples that i showed
is you can actually have fluency
configured
to talk to multiple backends with like
some of the secondary failover
knows so that like you're sending to
node a like all the time
then the node a stops responding to your
heartbeat then you actually fail
over to node b and start sending data
there
so if you have any other question you
can find me on twitter
that's actually the last slide that i
didn't even get to
there you go sure